[Music]
how much fun are you having right now at
this time of your life working so much
and being on TV it's definitely a change
because I was just a girl from
Pittsburgh and now I'm here walking the
team choice carpet so just crazy to see
how far I've come but definitely a dream
come true come far in a short amount of
time what are your big dreams your big
goals definitely gonna live in LA would
be successful you have a family you know
but I mean this already I mean who
wouldn't want to be here what are you
most excited for people to see coming up
on this oh wow this season is very
dramatic there's new cast members and we
have a new dance teacher who's coming on
so it's gonna be a good season I mean
miss Cheryl Burke how's that she's
amazing I love her so much and she gets
us because her schedule on Dancing with
the Stars is exactly like ours so she
knows how to get it done and she's great
and she's nice about it unlike the path
yes I mean do you consider yourself a
little traumatized from that how things
used to be a little bit but I made it
I'm kind of surprised I'm standing here
right now it was definitely a tough
journey but we all made it through so
now we get to go on to bigger and better
things
I mean how is everybody feeling about
this big change is her being nicer the
biggest part of it I mean it's
definitely changed for us but we just
needed to get away from the negative
energy because it's not good on us and
we just it's time to move on so it was
the right decision good well how and why
will people still be into the show with
it having such a different vibe than it
used to be oh gosh well I think a lot of
the people love to see the dancing but
the drama will always still be there I
mean there's always rivalry between not
just the kids
the moms too and of course the dance
teacher and the mom so it's probably one
of our best seasons did anybody talk to
Abby Lee before she had it into prison
no I was actually in Pittsburgh so I
didn't get to see her we saw there was
some footage of her eating mac and
cheese on her way in to play I did see
that
say about the but I mean good luck to
her and hope she's well where she is
think she'd ever come back to the show
and she gets out uh well I'm not sure if
the show we even go on when she gets out
but who knows I mean anything could
happen
[Music]